can we talk about unions in general then
what are the pros and cons of unions
so the interest the Union
maybe you can correct me if I'm wrong I
have a lot to learn both about the
economics and The Human Experience of a
union
the Union's interest is to um
what to protect
worker rights and to maximize worker
happiness not the success and the
productivity and the efficiency of a
company right no I would disagree
um so I think at Union's interest is in
what's collectively bargaining on behalf
of workers because in certain cases
um you know I am right now a manager at
uh the nation magazine right if I have a
problem with my working conditions or I
need a raise or whatever else I could
with my skill set my background my role
in the company I could go to my boss the
owner of the nation and say okay I need
to renegotiate my contract on these
terms I could bargain right now
if I was a ordinary worker at like a CVS
or something if I didn't like my
conditions and I went to my boss and
said hey I need a two dollar raise and
you know I need to like be home by 8 30
because you know I I have I have
obligations at home uh the boss would
probably say I'm sorry that's not
possible right you know maybe try the
Rite Aid down the street or the
Walgreens down the street or whatever
um now if I went to the boss at a place
like CVS or even better if all the
pharmaceutical suitable workers
um you know at Rite Aid CBS Walgreens
went to our bosses and said listen
um you know we collectively need to uh
uh two dollars more and and you know
better hours shorter shifts or whatever
else then they would probably have no
choice but to concede you have to
bargain collectively at any level if if
you're in a ordinary worker
um and there are some exceptions but
that's for certain highly skilled
workers but even in in those cases of
course all workers are skilled I mean
just the technical definition
um given in those cases a lot of those
workers have to bargain collectively as
well in order to get more more wealth
but but it's but they cannot make their
demands so excessive that their firm
gets out of business so to the workers
only uh are workers as long as they're
gained fully employed so often unions
will uh try to select their wage demands
at such a level that it ensures that
their firm will stay in business yeah
but the problem is the way firms go out
of business isn't by an explosion
uh like uh the way popcorn starts
getting cooked like you at a certain
moment it just is over
you can it seems like the union can
through uh collective bargaining keep
increasing the wage keeping increasing
the interest
of the worker until it suffocates the
company that it doesn't die immediately
but it dies in like five years so that
might still serve the interest of the
worker
but it doesn't serve the interest of
society as a whole that's creating cool
stuff and increasing so a market that's
operating and increasing cool stuff and
constant innovating and so on and uh
creating more and more cool stuff and
increasing the quality of life in
general I I disagree with the premise
because I think you're even taking your
example that would be better for society
if a firm cannot pay its workers a
living wage but its competitors can then
that firm should will either figure out
a way to innovate develop new techniques
new markets new ways to be productive or
it should go out of business and it
would be better for it to go out of
business than to stay in business or to
be artificially kept in business in any
sort of way
um and yeah so let me that's so that's a
Chrysler in my old um centralized
Department yeah right but but then there
is you know Innovation costs money too
so the flip side of that
I think to play Devil's Advocate is that
it incentivizes automotive industry is
it probably a good example of that it
incentivizes
uh cutting costs everywhere and sort of
whatever that's been making you money
currently figuring out how to do that
really well
without investing into the long-term
future of the company for like all the
different ways it can pivot all the
different interesting things it could do
in terms of investing into r d whenever
there's more and more and more pressure
I'm paying a living wage for the workers
it might not again it might suffocate
and die over the next 5 10 20 years
uh which might be
a good destructive force from a
capitalist perspective but it might rob
us of the Einstein of a company right of
the of the flourishing that the company
and the workers within it can do over a
period of 5 10 20 years well this is
just a problem with a lot of capitalism
which is about short-termism right
because the same thing could be said
from you're starting a company you have
a plan for it to make a lot of money but
your investors want you want dividends
right away so you have to uh
take away from your long-term r d or
other plans and deliver short-term uh
dividends that's often why a lot of I
think r d is often rooted in state
institutions and research and whatever
else is being drawn on and and also I
think that that's a reason why
you know the state has some sort of role
in fostering firms in either a my
version of a socialist economy or a
capitalist economy or whatever else to
help with these time Horizon uh problems
so I won't dispute that workers could
play a role or wage demands could play a
role in time Horizon problems but more
often than that it's coming from
investors it's coming from just a host
of other Market pressures that people
might might have and I would say that in
the real world a lot of investment funds
don't come from just retained earnings
it comes from a lot of you know sources
so I think this is a problem that could
be solved through public policy but
definitely exists today as well so you
mentioned living wage
is there is there a tension between a
living wage
and maybe you could speak to what a
living wage means and the workers owning
all of the profit of the company
sort of uh this kind of spectrum no I
guess the spectrum is from
like no no minimum wage the lowest
possible thing you could pay to a worker
than somewhere in that spectrum is a
living wage and then at the at the top
is like uh all of the profit from the
companies owned by the workers
so split to the workers
I mean I think that any society is going
to have to make distributional
um choices
um you could have imagine a variety of
capitalism in which workers are paid
quite little but there's extremely high
taxation and there's redistribution
after the fact you can imagine a system
in which there's less taxation after the
fact but there's more guarantees and
regulations how much people are paid
before the fact
in my vision of a social Society there
would be some other way that unions work
and in my exam these centralized
bargaining Unions would work that
bargain at the sectoral level and not
just at the Enterprise level like our
unions do do today
um
there could be benchmarks set for
different occupations or wages and the
reason why you would want to Benchmark
at a worker controlled firm is that you
don't want workers self-exporting
themselves in order to gobble up market
share or because you don't want them
collectively deciding okay we're going
to invest in this longer term time
Horizon and out-compete other people
that way so you might say okay if you do
this sort of clerical work you have to
be paid the equivalent of 15 an hour
that's minimum but on top of that you
get
um you get uh you know dividends from
from excess profits
um and I think it would also have to be
combined with
um public financing for expansions and
for development which could be done in
quite a competitive way so you could
have a variety of of banks you know in
my vision you know state-owned Banks but
what how would they decide who to
um invest in and who to not and invest
in who to give a loan for expansion to
and who not to because you don't want it
to be like Oh I'm going to invest in my
my nephew's firm and not this other firm
or I'm going to invest and this guy's
firm because he's an Italian but not
this guy's firm because he's Albanian or
whatever else just make it rational at
the level of their goal is just like any
other
um investment person at a bank today to
maintain a certain risk profile and to
have an interest yield
and decide to invest on on that basis so
if there's a huge Automotive firm that
has been on business for 50 years that
needs a little operating cash like yeah
they could get their 50 million dollars
their three percent loan if you have
some crazy blue sky idea and you manage
to get it to that that point like maybe
you knew friends would get it at you
know 12 or something close to whatever
VC would offer today so I only kind of
go into these details not because to say
that
a system doesn't have to in advance
map out all the different possibilities
but I think it does have to be willing
to accept a lot of things we know today
you know I can't give you a version of
socialism that's everything's going to
be fine we're going to live harmoniously
and we won't have these sort of tensions
and you know you could hunt in the
evening and you know fish in the you
know afternoon and write criticism you
know whatever else
um I do hope that there's Horizons
Beyond this that we could aspire to I do
have those Visions but for now I think
our task as socialists is to imagine a
you know five minutes after you know
midnight like what what can we do right
away within our lifetime
um Vision so that means
through some level of central planning
reallocating resources to the workers
so I think the primary mechanism in this
private sector under socialism would be
a market mechanism firms competing
against each other to expand uh
connected to a system of public
financing but even at that level the
individual
um bankers and and public Banks and so
on would be operating based on their own
rationality and the state would
certainly shape investment decisions but
maybe no more than they do in a lot of
capitalist systems so the state might
already today and a lot of countries
decide
you know we want to invest in Green
Technology so it's going to be favorable
rates for people or tax credits for
people investing in Green Technology so
the state already shapes investment
um I think what should be centrally
planned and this is where like I'm proud
to sound like an old school socialist is
things like um Healthcare things like um
Transit things like our
um natural monopolies of lots of types
uh you know I think can be done very
well through
um through planning and we already have
plenty of examples but a lot of this
Society I think would be would be the
the private sphere of worker controlled
cooperatives uh competing against each
other weak firms failing successful
firms expanded